le cfm56 c'est cela un réacteur champion
du monde de sa catégorie
un moteur qui totalisent plus de 10
millions huit cent cinquante mille
heures de vol fruit d'une coopération
industrielle exemplaire
il est construit des deux côtés de
l'atlantique ici dans les usines
françaises de la snecma et en amérique
chez le partenaire general electric
ce moteur ultra moderne bénéficie d'une
solide réputation de fiabilité 50 moteur
sortent des chaînes d'assemblage chaque
mois 5000 exemplaires seront livrés en
1992 pour 3500 comment déjà
d'où la surprise à l'aspect quoi créer
par l'amour de l'accident britannique
statistiquement il n'existe qu'un risque
sur 10 millions pour que deux moteurs
tombe en panne
au même instant sur un avion dès
l'annoncé de la catastrophe
la snecma a envoyé sur place trois
experts ceci n'est carte à l'heure
actuelle aucune hypothèse
les deux moteurs serait peut-être
effectivement tombés en panne
simultanément
ou bien les techniciens de la
maintenance au sol ont pu commettre une
erreur de remontage chez le constructeur
boeing
les moteurs ont pu également être
assemblés sur l'avion avec des erreurs
enfin comme cela s'est déjà produit dans
le passé
les techniciens de boeing ont peut être
mal monté les extincteurs laissant ainsi
le feu ce communiqué d'un moteur à l'eau